مع تصاعد التوترات بعد الاصطدام
بين طائرة روسية وطائرة أمريكية بدون طيار
فوق البحر الأسود، أخبرني رئيس الناتو أن
الحلف يقف بقوة خلف
الولايات المتحدة ما رأيته هو أه
سلوك متهور وغير مسؤول من جانب
روسيا الذي أدى إلى هذا الحادث في البحر
الأسود  الشيء الجيد في البحر هو أن
الولايات المتحدة تتصرف بشكل أكثر
احترافية
وأن الأمن في البحار يمثل قضية كبيرة
بالنسبة لحلف شمال الأطلسي، فقد سافرنا بالطائرة إلى أحد
أكبر حقول الغاز في أوروبا مع الأمين
العام ورئيس مفوضية الاتحاد الأوروبي
بينما كانت سفن الناتو الحربية
تحرس البحر.  إن
حلفاء الولايات المتحدة، الذين يراقبون أعمال التخريب المحتملة، يدركون جيدًا
أن حرب روسيا في أوكرانيا تشكل تهديدًا
ليس فقط للسماء فوق البحار وفي
البحار، ولكن أيضًا للبنية
التحتية الحيوية تحت البحر أيضًا،
وهذا هو السبب وراء تعزيز حلف الناتو.
وتتمثل جهودها لحماية هذه
البنية التحتية الحيوية في
الآبار الفعلية لحقل غاز ترول، حيث
تأتي 10 من إمدادات الغاز الطبيعي لحلفاء أمريكا الأوروبيين من هذا
الحقل وحده بعد أن توقف معظمهم عن
شراء الغاز من روسيا
العام الماضي، وخط أنابيب نورد ستريم
بين ألمانيا وروسيا.  تم تفجيره
فيما تقول الولايات المتحدة إنه عمل
تخريبي بينما يعتقد البعض أن الأوكرانيين
قد يكونون وراء الانفجار،
وتنفي كييف تورطها،
ويقول لي رئيس مفوضية الاتحاد الأوروبي إن أوروبا ستواصل
دعم أوكرانيا، ونحن نعلم في
الاتحاد الأوروبي أن أوكرانيا لا تقاتل فقط
من أجل استقلالها وسيادتها
وحريتها ولكن أيضًا من أجل القيم الحيوية التي
نتقاسمها مثل احترام
القانون الدولي
ويقول الأوكرانيون إنهم سيقاتلون
على مفتاح القول إن المعارك الأكثر عنفًا لا تزال
تدور حول
باكموت حيث يدعي الروس أنهم
ينتصرون  ويقال إن
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
سيلتقي بالزعيم الصيني شي جين بينغ
في موسكو الأسبوع المقبل حيث
يتطلع الروس إلى تعميق العلاقات بشكل أكبر
وتعتقد الولايات المتحدة أنها تريد من بكين أن تمنحهم
أسلحة
يقول زعيم الناتو إن الأمن في أوروبا
لن يكون مضمونًا إلا إذا انتهى بوتين
الحرب ضد أوكرانيا هي أفضل طريقة
للحد من مخاطر حوادث مثل هذه، وهي
بالطبع مطلوبة لإنهاء
الحروب العالمية الخطيرة وتؤدي إلى
مواقف خطيرة مثل حادثة
اللقاح ولكن طالما
استمرت الحرب، يقول الناتو إن سفنه ستبقى
في حالة تأهب لحماية
البنية التحتية الحيوية لأعضاء التحالف من الهجمات المحتملة